[Applause]
too much pressure too unfair Liverpool
manager Jurgen klopp told Sky News it
wasn't right to ask players to address
human rights issues at the World Cup in
Qatar with the tournament just weeks
away and still so much controversy about
the host nation
the decision was made by other people
and if you want to criticize anybody
then criticize the people who made the
decision not the sport not the
competition and not for sure not the
players so
um and now it's not fair as well that we
expect prominent that they go there and
make big political
statements or whatever it's just not
fair shaped our country some players
have spoken out already this was team
Australia this week as players we fully
support the rights of the lgbti plus
people but in Qatar people are not free
to love the person that they choose and
Harry Kane England Captain has stated
he'd like to wear a rainbow armband
championing LGBT plus rights in Qatar
where same-sex relationships are legally
prohibited Mr klopp said he absolutely
supported Harry Kane's decision but
their expectations on individual players
were too intense these boys they were 10
years old when there had been the
decisions were made and how they should
be in any kind of situation where they
could be criticized for no way no chance
pressure on them to be Advocates it's
what you what you do in a moment if you
ask me that question for me it's no
problem but you ask them the question
yes then you put pressure on them and
that's not fair
Mr klopp spoke to Sky News ahead of
receiving this the freedom of Liverpool
presented for his on-pitch success as
well as his off-pitch advocacy on issues
from climate change to covid to the cost
of living he said it was common sense
for someone with his platform and
experience to engage in these debates
but that younger players needed to be
protected and simply allowed to play
Catherine evertotsi Sky News in
Liverpool